brooke burke says she'd love to co-host
live with Kelly Ripa I'd love to go next
to Kelly news broke in April that
Michael Strahan is leaving life for good
morning america and ever since there's
been tons of speculation about who would
replace him one person who wants the gig
former Dancing with the Stars host
brooke burke the 44 year-old opened up
to ET on thursday at the operation smile
gala in new york city where she revealed
the personal reason why she'd love to
join the show I love Kelly and I
actually would love to get you know in
the rounds four co-hosts and you know
what also I feel her I mean I had a
similar experience at ABC sort of
blindsided and you know I think that
she's handling it really well and I
fully understand what she's going
through and you know kind of woman to
woman been there Andy Cohen Neil Patrick
Harris and Kelly's close pal Anderson
Cooper have all been rumored to be in
the running to fill stray hands role
however a source connected to the search
for the new co-host tells ET their quote
definitely looking for someone more
ethnically diverse who's your top pick
let us know on twitter at ET now